i'm gay
yes queer history was made back in 1997
when ellen became the first primetime
sitcom to feature a gay lead character
et caught up with ellen that same year
where she spoke about the series making
a difference
in this business you get so caught up in
ratings and what it's all about and to
know that no matter what happens i've
made a difference in
in the time that i'm spending here i i
know that i've done something really
good and more important than having my
own sitcom so
that's a good feeling another memorable
tv moment is patrick coming out to his
parents on shit's creek it was simply
the best
we're together
david is my boyfriend
and i've never been happier in my life
i don't think we could have hoped for a
more generous and loving response from
our fans and
to see that storyline means so much to
so many people it's it's really
incredibly rewarding this is us also
featured a beautiful moment it's long
been a dream of mine that you never ever
it's because i think i might like girls
a beautiful young girl damned me i mean
her mom too and they were saying how not
only did tess help the daughter but it
helped her mom and i thought that was
really cool as well because it's not
only helping the kids or these people
it's helping parents understand their
children and i think that's so important
we love
you matter what okay
the series glee featured many emotional
coming out scenes like when kurt told
his friend mercedes and then his father
i'm gay
i know
really i've known since you were three
and marco coming out on degrassi the
next generation was impactful for both
audiences and its star
explain it to me because obviously i'm a
[ __ ] and don't get it because man
because why because i'm okay
i came out also through marco so you
know we kind of grew up together
we figured it out together and it was
incredible that the show at that time
was able to start that conversation so i
see marco often as a conversation
starter and now over the last 20 years
to see how that conversation has
progressed is incredible thanks
[Music]